زد ينضم الينا من رفح مراسلنا هشام زقوط
هشام اهلا بك عن الغاره التي استهدفت
منزلا في حي الجنينه وباقي
التطورات مريم الغاره الاسرائيليه على رفح
استشهد جراءها ثلاثه من الفلسطينيين من
بينهم سيده وما زال هناك بعض الفلسطينيين
من جراء هذا الاستهداف تحت الانقاض ف نحن
نتحدث عن مدينه رفح والاستهداف في رفح
لمنزل وهذا المنزل بالتاكيد سيكون م ظ
بالسكان كما نعلم لان رفح ربما هي المدينه
الاكثر كثافه سكانيه في العالم النازحون
في رفح جاؤوا من كل مناطق قطاع غزه ولجوا
الى هذه المدينه الصغيره وبالتالي المنازل
مكتظه عن بكره ابيها
واستهدفت الغاره الاسرائيليه منزلا في حي
الجنينه شرق مدينه رفح ودمرته وسوته
بالارض وبالتالي كان هناك عشرات من
المفقودين جراء هذا الاستهداف بالاضافه
الى الشهداء الثلاثه الذين نقلوا الى
مستشفى ابو يوسف النجار في مدينه رفح هذه
الغاره ربما هي الاعنف على مدينه رفح خلال
الساعات الماضيه لكن كان هناك ايضا غاره
على مدينه دير البلح حيث ايضا اوقعت عدد
من الاصابات والشهداء في منطقه حكر الجامع
وما زالت ايضا مدينه خانيونس هي التي
تتعرض الى الغارات والقصف الاكثر عنفا
والاكثر حده في قطاع غزه خاصه ان الدبابات
الاسرائيليه مازالت تتوغل في مناطق مختلفه
في المنطقه
الغربيه مدينه خانيونس ايضا قصفتها
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه في محيط مجمع ناصر
ما زال الذي ما زال محاصرا قصفت المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه تلك المناطق والمنازل المدنيه
الفلسطينيه في هذه المنطقه الجيش
الاسرائيلي يكثف من عملياته في مدينه
خانيونس وبالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي مازال
مستمر لكنه ربما في هذه الليله كان الاقل
حده ربما منذ بدايه الحرب الاسرائيليه
الجيش الاسرائيلي على ما يبدو وفي ظل
الظروف السيئه انخفضت حده الغارات انخفض
القصف الاسرائيلي رغم انه كان ما بين فينه
واخرى هناك غارات اسرائيليه لكن المعركه
للفلسطينيين كانت مختلفه الليله الماضيه
كانت
معركه يواجهون فيها بردا قارص يواجهون
فيها رياحا عاتيه يواجهون فيها احوال جويه
سيئه وهم في خيام وبالتالي كانت هناك
عشرات من الخيام التي اقتلعت من جراء هذه
الرياح العاتيه والرياح الشديده ده وغرقت
مئات من الخيام للنازحين الفلسطينيين
حاولوا توفير الدفئ لابنائهم لكنهم لم
يفلحوا في ذلك فالظروف صعبه والامكانات
بسيطه الامكانات صعبه للغايه توفير
الامكانات صعب للغايه في ظل هذه الظروف
مئات بل الاف من النازحين الفلسطينيين من
مدينه خان يونس كانوا بلا غطاء بلا ماوى
بلا اي نوع من انواع الفراش لان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اجبرهم على النزوح من من مدينه
خان يونس بدون ان يحصلوا على اي شيء وبدون
ان يحضروا اي من اغطيتي او فراشهم او حتى
الخيم اي هم عاشوا العشرات بل الاف مئات
الالاف من النازحين نحن نتحدث عن مليون
و300 ال فلسطيني يعيشون في مدينه رفح
300,000 هم السكان الاصليين فهذا يعني ان
مليون نازح في مدينه رفح عاشوا الليله
الماضيه في ليله صعبه كانوا يحاولون بكل
شتى الوسائل ان يحصلوا على الدفئ وان
يوفروا الدفئ لابنائهم لكنهم لم يفلحوا في
ذلك فاللي كانت ربما من الليالي الاكثر
قسوه والاكثر بروده وبالتالي كان توفير
الدفئ هو المعركه الاهم بالنسبه لهؤلاء
وايضا ان يحصلوا وان يؤمنوا الفراش وان لا
تغرق هذه الفراش التي هي من الصعب الحصول
عليها في ظل هذه الظروف السيئه وفي ظل نقص
النقص الحاد في المستلزمات والادويه
والغذاء والماء وايضا الفراش فالفراش غير
متوفر لعشرات بل مئات من النازحين
الفلسطينيين الذين اتوا من خانيونس والذين
اتوا من كل انحاء القطاع كما نعرف فان
الخيام نصبت في خانيونس في رفح في المناطق
الغربيه وهي المناطق القريبه من البحر
وبالتالي كانت الليله الاشد بروده عليهم
وفي ظل هذه الامطار ربما لم نشهد امطارا
كهذه من قبل منذ بدء فصل الشتاء و
وبالتالي كانت الحرب الليله منصبه على
توفير هذا الدفئ لهؤلاء الاطفال ولهذه
العائلات الفلسطينيه التي عاشت ليله صعبه
وهي تحاول انلا تغرق خيامها انلا تغرق
فراشه وان يوفروا الدفئ لاطفالهم لكن رغم
كل ذلك هم فشلوا في ذلك هشام زقوت من رفح
شكرا جزيلا
لك